[Music]
look at that
look at that look at that that
is smarter than you why who thinks he's
smarter than you why who thinks he's
smarter than you
this is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers
specifically
[Music]
corporate
[Music]
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
[Music]
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
a loser pac-man's a loser
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone ladies and gentlemen
alex jones
is now
very very upset with me
look at that that is a freaking predator
right there
who thinks he's smarter than you thinks
he's better than you and he's going to
beat you pac-man never talked to the new
orleans pac-man's a loser
man's a loser he's not a knight at the
round table that's true
i'm not a knight at the round that that
actually is accurate that dude is gone
ladies and gentlemen
i was telling my children
[Music]
destiny
[Music]
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elephants and bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of bathrooms
ten times
[Music]
of bathrooms
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
mangoes
[Music]
i love mangoes
[Music]
bag
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
for the wisconsin crowd
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
well welcome everybody what a day we
have today so much to discuss and i am
really glad that you are here um things
are getting really really really crazy
with the russian invasion of ukraine and
you know many of you
i don't want to say my audience is
confused i just we're all sort of trying
to make sense of two competing
narratives which which really did they
compete but they both coexist one
narrative is
a lot of really dumb stuff is happening
that russia is doing like for example
their big tank convoy
is moving like three miles a day
because um they're like out of gas and
out of food and you know all this
different crazy stuff so like that's one
component of what's going on at the same
time
the russian military is so enormous that
they are also starting to take ukrainian
cities putin reportedly told the french
president emmanuel macron that he plans
to take everything
everything everything everything take
all of ukraine and how could there be so
much incompetence and we've heard about
the soldiers surrendering and calling
mommy
and being like i don't know what i'm
doing sir and all this different stuff
all of this stuff is happening at the
same time because so much is going on at
once
um so we're just gonna go through all of
it really uh and uh remains to be seen
ultimately what's going to happen so
first and foremost very very big news
russia has seized its first major
ukrainian city it's the city of carson
it's a close to 300 000 population
and the mayor is begging putin not to
keep killing civilians oh boy
russia has taken its first major city in
ukraine after days of fierce battles
the mayor
uh and that where is this down here
um
at least 300 civilians and soldiers have
been killed
where is this quote from the mayor
ah igor kolikayev the mayor of kursan
confirmed the city's capture last night
as he begged russians not to shoot
civilians
i simply asked them not to shoot people
making the point we don't have any
ukrainian forces in the city it's only
civilians and people here who want to
live so that's one piece of what's going
on now you've got to hold the city as
people are pointing out and then holding
the city can be difficult
meanwhile vladimir putin says violence
will get worse and his plan is to take
all of ukraine
as if we didn't know that was his plan
um russia's attack on ukraine is going
according to plan and the violence will
get worse putin warned today
the russian president made the alarming
comments to emmanuel macron his french
counterpart during a phone call
after hanging up the phone
at the end of the exchange which lasted
an hour and a half mccrone said the
worst is yet to come
a spokesman for macron said president
putin expressed his very great
determination to continue the offensive
the aim of which is to take control of
the whole country putin said the russian
army operation was developing according
to plan and it will get worse if
ukrainians don't surrender now putin
may not be telling the truth that
everything's going according to plan i
mean i don't think your tanks being out
of gas
is part of anybody's plan if that's part
of a plan it's a very dumb plan so
obviously no matter what putin would say
everything's going according to plan
it may or may not be we don't know
uh the ominous sentiment is particularly
unwelcome as it comes as the russian and
ukrainians sit down together for a
second time to try to reach a ceasefire
agreement there appears to be
significant distance between the two
sides demands yes that's an
understatement
uh ukrainian foreign minister dimitro
culeba said that while his country is
ready for talks to resume russia's
demands haven't changed and he won't
accept any ultimatums russian officials
say moscow's demands include ukraine's
recognition of russia's hold on crimea
as well as independence for the donetsk
and luhansk regions as well as
demilitarization and denotification the
jewish ukrainian president it's like how
can i be less of a nazi i don't even
know
so that's not going particularly well
in the meantime
the u.s has charged
a russian oligarchs tv producer with
violating crimea related sanctions this
is pretty interesting
u.s prosecutors in manhattan today
charged tv producer constantine malofiev
malafayev
with violating sanctions the producer
u.s citizen john hannock
was arrested in february in london the
us wants him extradited and they said he
violated sanctions from the 2014
invasion
mulliphaev owns sargrad tv which is a
christian orthodox channel he was
sanctioned eight years ago
and his producer
is now been has now been indicted it'll
be very very interesting to see
whether those charges stick i hope they
do indeed throw the book at him and by
the way
i
this is kind of just good news i have to
tell you i'm taking pleasure in this
rt america has shut down and fired
everybody
you know a lot of really bad things are
going on
but this is just delightful this is just
delightful and our friends farron
cousins and mike pap antonio bailed last
week and they were right to do so um and
you know we've all been talking about
like what is the future of rt america
now understand this is not rt fully this
is just rt america
um
this is uh
this is pretty pretty pretty good news i
have to tell you
uh kremlin-funded rt america shuts down
lays off almost everybody
tnr productions which is the company
that handles operations has laid off
almost everybody in shuttered production
in an all hand oh it's misha i know this
dude i've i've talked to this guy
what's appropriate for me to say
so here's a misha story
um
when i was at at this at a conference in
vegas
um
i uh i you know i i got to vegas and i i
hit the gym
as i often like to do
and then i come out of the gym
and uh misha's there and i've met him a
couple times he's told me he's a fan of
the show and it's like dude are you are
you like trying to run me what does that
even mean you're a fan of the show
um
and misha is like oh when'd you get in
and i was like today
he's like oh you don't want to work it
you don't want to work out for 24 hours
after getting off a flight and i was
like really misha why what do you mean
and he's like it um
your your blood pressure it's that you
could you can get very sick because your
blood pressure hasn't adjusted and i was
like oh my god i hope i'm okay i'm
already done with my workout and then i
went back and i was talking to my
girlfriend i was like wait a second
the entire american sports industry is
based on athletes traveling around
getting off planes and within 24 hours
playing
full speed professional sports
i was like that can't possibly be right
and then i actually looked it up and
spoke to
some actual doctors that were there at
the same conference they were like i've
never heard of that
so anyway misha i think was just trying
to prevent me from developing extremely
swollen muscles that's that's my misha
story actually a perfectly nice guy but
anyway so misha says it's done it's over
there has been an unforeseen business
interruption events
effective a media immediately the layoff
will be permanent and this is the
permanent separation but guys i think
that this is this is absolutely fine
news and i have to tell you you know
there's all these people who are like oh
but it's free what about free speech
guys
let's think it through piece by piece
no
cable outlet
has to air rt
okay no cable outlet has to air rt
it is russian state propaganda but if
media outlets want to run it if if
you know
what are cable car i don't even know
what are cable companies comcast or
whoever
if they
i would love
my show is on free speech tv a channel
called free speech tv i would love
comcast to take free speech tv i would
love everybody to take it
but they don't have any
responsibility to do that no more than
i'd love to speak at mit but if mit
doesn't invite me i have no right to it
so
every single one of these cable stations
um
can decide what they want to run or what
they don't want to run
and if it doesn't become financially
viable then they then they shut down
that's it's just that simple now
separately there's the question of
sanctions and
if the united states sanctions russian
companies then media companies would
fall under that as well i mean i just i
just don't really know what the argument
is it's just business yes green man
thank you
um
so this i consider this good uh i'm all
for diversity of ideas but these aren't
even good faith ideas do do we really
need the pro-invasion
propaganda side if uh media if cable
companies don't want to run it
give me a break guys so anyway we're
saying goodbye to rt as many of you know
i've previously appeared on rt but for
the last like five years they've invited
me maybe maybe 10 times i just don't do
it i just say no thank you i'm not not
interested not able to do it
and that's it guys that's it so bye bye
we are standing by for president
that's president sir
um
joe biden who is going to be signing
some stuff into law very very soon as
you can see here but we have so many
other things to look at let me make sure
i properly thank everybody
oh jack says via super chat david who
are you supporting for the senate race
in wisconsin i don't even know who's
running yet
i don't know who's running yet i'm going
to look at that
let me say thank you to some really
great people who are supporting me on
twitch that includes shara hill jen here
cosmos harry
iriman sheldon black
and physicist very much appreciate you
guys those are numbers one through seven
as you can see here
jeffrey says david remember the
batmobile from the christian bale movies
do those exist outside the fictional
world and if so could we
send those to ukraine i do not know
whether the batmobiles are real vehicles
i really don't
uh you can if you would like and i would
suggest you do so
sign up on my website with the coupon
code please don't war it is an anti-war
message of peace and love please don't
war you can use that code on my website
and i will thank everybody absolutely
everybody will get a thank you oh and
also thanks to brain matter new member
number eight today okay i have four
unbanned requests to adjudicate as we
wait for joe biden
here's what it means on when someone
requests an unban
specifically on twitch if you get banned
and a lot of people got banned over the
last week you can appeal it you can say
no i don't want to be banned and you can
send me a message as to why
all right let's see if anybody deserves
an unban request user raving mage showed
up during the state of the union and
said
i hope biden's dementia doesn't lead to
world war iii
i can't believe biden would fail this
much barely being in office but it's
amazing to mock his idiot followers
first biden and obama let russia take
crimea now biden lets ukraine fall
uh i would take that over president
craps's pants it's hysterical watching
biden fail
he must have appealed to dead and
imaginary voters okay so they were
banned that's all sorts of
disinformation their unbanned messages i
did nothing wrong that is a permaban
we just don't we don't just don't accept
it here
a user no we poo
showed up and said do something [ __ ]
damn f word biden
they were banned
and their unbanned request was i don't
know
perma
permaban
user dark master minecraft showed up
and said
mr pakmir
i don't like russia mr pakmir who is the
woman with the flag mr pakmir what do
you call people degenerates mr pakmir is
kamala going to be the next president mr
pakmir was this the nuclear slip mr
pakmir did biden declare war mr pakmir i
don't like miss harris mr pakmir this
didn't crap you up you just like the
money they were banned
and then their unban request is why do i
get the ban i like your streamer ring
sir i don't understand sometime is that
the so bad that's a perma-ban
unintelligible completely unintelligible
and last one here let's go brandon and
then they were banned and their unban
request is all we have to do is type
let's go brandon yes that's a permaban
so four for four
all we went all perma today guys
and some people don't like that some
people do quite frankly i don't care
uh you guys have fun with that
okay let's continue
um
russia is warning
that they uh that hacking their
satellites would be an act of war
after anonymous claim to have breached
space defenses i want to hear from you
guys about your opinion
but my instinct is that elements of
cyber hacks are going to become
extraordinarily pro prominent in this
war if the war goes on more than just an
additional few days
okay
uh i think it is very likely that there
will be simultaneously at least three
front fronts of this war they will be
the the physical front where russia's
tanks have this 40 mile long convoy
that's out of gas and all this different
stuff that's number one number two there
will be the cyber front and number three
there will be the diplomatic front where
negotiations in theory will be will be
taking place
maybe not particularly good faith ones
but there will be negotiations and
russia is very strongly warning now why
do we care about russia's warnings we
care about russia's warnings not because
it's like oh wow well we better be
it's because
any of these warnings
could be the setup to a pretext to
nuclear war and of course we don't think
it's very likely
but one of the things you have to think
about is what's the expected value and
is the expected so if you're like well i
think there's a 90 chance biden i'm
sorry biden there's a hundred percent
chance biden won't use nukes if there's
a 90 chance that putin won't use nukes
and a 10 chance that he will
that 10
chance
is so damaging
if you think about the expected value
that you've still got to take it
extremely seriously and at this point in
time it's a crazy guy with nukes and
that's why you've got to take it very
seriously so whenever putin starts
saying if you do this it's an act of war
if you do that it's an act of war
i mean listen you you gotta you've got
to take it at least somewhat seriously
so that's going on and it's very very
scary
um
this crowd of a hundred and twenty
thousand
was out in hamburg germany today in
support of ukraine
unbelievable now donald trump said this
was only 300 people
uh i don't know trump and crowd sizes as
you know very very confusing it's
unclear what the guy understands no i'm
kidding i don't think trump has
commented on this but an incredible
incredible crowd
uh let me see if i do that no this we're
gonna get to later okay here is
president joe biden announcing new
sanctions on dozens of additional
russian oligarchs banning them from
coming into the united states today i'm
announcing that we're adding dozens of
names to the list including
one of russia's wealthiest billionaires
and i'm
banning travel to america by
by more than
50 russian oligarchs their families and
their close associates
and we're going to continue to support
ukrainian people all right so you know
not the the biggest biggest deal he is
banning some men
and we will ban men yup biden doing it
he's banning quite a few men
and uh that's uh yeah i think he's gonna
obviously this is going to continue and
whether it has any real impact we're
gonna wait and see
lauren beaubert who recently heckled joe
biden when he was talking about his
deceased son during the state of the
union she appeared with
this dude i don't know who this is benny
this is benny and uh well i won't even
tell you what she said here's what she
had to say about russian sanctions
pelosi was being really weird i mean do
you know of anything going on behind the
scenes with nancy pelosi what's going on
with her can you tell our audience
this is like the biggest meme so when
they both talk at the same time we don't
know what they're saying but coming out
other than you and other than you uh
chad oh my god this guy is smitten with
bo bear isn't he
this guy is just smitten at the
president you have me off of social
media right now she sounds like she's
steam it like she's uh uh streaming
from a uh from a tiled shower yeah very
very echo-y nerd i have my ipad here and
i want to keep checking it and i can't
wait
you must know you must be privy to a lot
of like gossip and a lot of inside
information can they even hear each
other
do you guys think they can't even were
these things report recorded
asynchronously it's bizarre
what's going on here here's what i think
happened um i think that uh the the
russian sanctions on the sanctions on
russian vodka have kicked in
and
that's i love that fake laugh
um
so
that was so funny this guy almost fell
off his seat look at did you see that
he's like
and
uh nancy pelosi losing it um
so i i don't
[Applause]
know what else to say i'm so glad you
saw what we saw because um there was
definitely some malfunctioning there
going on and i don't know if that was
withdrawals or she's trying to get in
all she's got uh before it's too late um
her mouth was going at me her mouth was
going crazy that's m a h l f mouth
maybe that's why we've had the mask so
long maybe there's something going on
there you know and a little compulsion
there that you can't control uh and the
mask has been covering it all along
yeah um i i actually don't know where
the cringe is is it on the left side of
the screen or is it on the
the right side of the screen it's
bizarre guys really really strange stuff
uh man what yeah i know it's like what
are they even talking about it's it i
have no idea it's it's all completely
nuts
i want to say thank you to blueberry
babe d4 rel nate's techie 420 weed bong
brain matter
uh one two three four five six
six plus eight is fourteen very much
appreciate that
uh okay
what coupon codes are available today
that's a great question well listen if
you look right above my head you see the
coupon code please don't war
please don't war you can use that on my
website the coupon code obama is still
available
and the coupon code sad trump
sad trump is still available uh will i
give away any items sure yeah sure i
mean at this point we may be losing
money on these free items we it's uh one
person who got a free item last week is
from from australia so now we're
shipping stuff to australia the first so
these 14 people have all been twitch
people the first person to use
a uh uh i double counted brain matter oh
but svenhaut just signed up so we're
still at 14. uh net first person to sign
up on my website joinpakman.com i'll
send you a free item from my online
store almost everybody picks the coffee
mug but there are t-shirts and other
other different things uh thanks trisha
for the subscription
first person to sign up on the website i
will send you a free item it's wide open
right now
um
yes even with a discount code
even with a discount code i don't care
you pay 1.80 cents i'll still send you a
free item that cost me 15 bucks
isn't that generous all right other
super chats coming in
no no super chats
hold on i thought i had one here
here it is sir can i have an obama oh
sure obama thank you
uh
i appreciate that do i have any pacman
hair products not at this time
uh but it's something i would look at
developing something
why not
uh okay
um couple yeah i guess we could do no
let's do let's do something else okay do
you guys remember this ex saturday night
live act actor victoria jackson who
completely lost her mind
she
appeared um
where was it let me see where this was
she appeared somewhere in tennessee
to talk about how
i don't even know what she's talking
about it's really crazy take a listen to
this she's very sick very very sick
woman the communist party usa their
goals are happening people are stealing
the innocence of children this is not a
character voice this is really her voice
my innocence was never stolen that's why
i am the way i am i talked to my own
sheriff and he said he didn't know
whether to hug me or go start putting
people in handcuffs this wicked book me
and earl and the dying girl sexually
indoctrinated with wicked vile books i
guess they're against books certain
books and she believes in traditional
marriage between a man and a woman and
in that book it talked about two moms
teachers many times who may have used
these same books to groom students that
have maybe molested uh students just is
there any evidence of that does anybody
know is there any evidence that that
happened
that we know of anyway
nobody no no of course yeah
nobody is reviewing the library books
but i thank god that we did pull our
kids out of school our oldest child
who's 13 now her peers in public school
have been exposed to this material it's
had developmental harm emotional harm
done to them can you imagine reading
they want us to believe reading
delays development that that's just
i mean it's i would call it beyond
parody but it's it's definitely
something people who have had their
families come from any communist country
will warn you this is how it starts
they're promoting pornhub this is being
promoted in schools i understand the
real agenda behind this push and it's a
sexual rights agenda for children that's
coming down the pipeline via government
schools and the real agenda is to lower
the age of consent and promote
pedophilia
right
the secret reason to have children read
is to promote pedophilia it's post
satire yeah books also use social issues
to slide the pornography into the books
when the light of the bible is removed
what is left is darkness and evil
pornography it can be very addictive
would we
leave heroin needles sitting out in
schools never mind the middle schoolers
how many adults have mastered critical
thinking skills while they're horny
listen very few adult you don't even
need to put in that last part i mean
very few adults have mastered critical
thinking skills
you could stop there you know i don't
even you don't even really need to go
further
if it is true according to reader
response theory that readers experience
promoting pornhub who who did you say
was
voting for planned parenthood federation
of america wasn't it ted cruz who
tweeted out who tweeted that porn
dictates a lot of the national standards
for comprehensive sexuality education i
could get you a you know a list of
states that it has been if you would
send that to my office thank you
absolutely
very very powerful legislative
legislation
um patrick says i landed on a right-wing
youtube and my brain hurt i am swiss
it is probably a school system that's
subpar in the u.s
sir a bit of a riddle what does your
hair and trump's wife have in common
that i think i have an answer to hold on
do i have it here
oh no wait a second
he said where
what happened to all of my audio clips
they're gone
wait a second oh here it is
sir your wife is up in the air there we
go i thought i thought i lost my clips
um thank you david for streaming the
state of the union oh it's kyoko kyoko's
called in before his speech may have
been graded bee-ish but he would get a
standing ovation in my country we don't
have a single leader who can deliver a
speech i can't say with certitude
whether that's true
sir can we get trump saying law markers
on the sound board if any i didn't i
don't remember trump saying law markers
instead of lawmakers if anybody can find
that and get it to me i would love that
all right guys you should we announce
who who is getting the um
the free item from my online store
should i do that or should i just keep
everybody waiting
for no reason at all
we'll announce it
um the first person today who signed up
on my website
and the proud soon-to-be owner
of a um
uh item
is emiliano rice emiliano rice signed up
on my website with the coupon code
please don't war
emiliano you can email info
davidpakman.com to collect
i want to say thanks to kyle freeman as
well as christopher asquith
theresa wright
jennifer elm green
jason robinson and indy jones indie
jones i like that
all of whom signed up on my website
putting us at 24. i really appreciate
that guys we actually have been taking
some pretty big hits lately the tool
sells
mass canceling memberships to my website
so when you sign up on my website
envision that you're replacing a tool
cell
just even whether you literally are or
not
um okay
let's do a couple voicemails
uh thanks to adam david lee as well as
lat west sorry for the twitch prime
subscriptions appreciate that as well
yeah the tool c stands i have a thousand
voicemails and some of them are bonkers
truly truly bonkers and i hesitate to
even get into this with you guys
but let's see
uh
i want to say that if you think that uh
lauren barber um
former congressman wilson
telling obama you lie
and or if you think that
lauren roberts uh
her comment was the worst thing ever
as a student union speech all right so
that's troy i mean it's it's as usual
it's it's uh kind of gutter trash
hayley says sir they should ban the
bible first characters are completely
naked that's not even that there's much
worse than that in there haley but yes
absolutely by their standards the bible
should be banned uh here's eric from
mass
hey david it's out for math uh
five the dogs have ended the discussion
i was right i tried to tell you i begged
you to listen tried to reason with you
sent you evidence
i want i was willing to show you videos
you told me to [ __ ] off what can you
possibly say now
the mental gymnastics on this will be
beyond priceless but the one thing i
will say is anybody know what he's
talking about does anybody have any idea
what he's talking about here's whitney
so i made a mistake the leo is the esfp
and then the one that's not like a
birthright is the infp it's not a zodiac
sign so there's the infj and the type
says the moon
and then istp and that type says
masculine and then infp which types as
um feminist
pretty big brain take guys
hey david it's eric from mass um
i agree that was the most disgusting
vile thing i've seen
and i'm talking about what you did lying
about what vulvar did she didn't even
know he was talking about uh
his son both um
and you sit there with an angry look on
your face but you don't give a [ __ ]
about the thirteen who died
you are a disgrace i don't even know
understand why you are in this country
if you [ __ ] hate it so much well
i'm a citizen i mean what do you mean
why why are you here i don't even know
why is anybody here what a strange thing
to say back to troy york hi hi david
this is arnold uh armstrong
um i i'm wondering why does the elect
and people like you
keep uh
arguing about uh
arguing trump about what he said about
uh vladimir putin
being uh
smart in a genius um yeah okay all right
thank you troy very good back to eric
from mouse
hey david eric from math the fizer
documents are out and i just want to say
hey
hey
you've got people hurt killed do you
guys know what fisa documents he's
talking about or is he saying pfizer
with a boston accent i actually can't
tell i know it is eric from mass
did he mean pfizer with a boston accent
or is he saying faisa
fisa
zara macho asks should the west cut off
russian oil liquefied national natural
gas and wheat exports
these exports are uh funding putin's war
in ukraine and possibly more right
yeah but they're also you know food for
people so i i think we just got to be
really careful about anything that could
um
you know end up leading to people
starving we got to be very very careful
with that
thank you to jennifer heard jennifer
just signed up on my website
joinedpacman.com jennifer thank you
i really really appreciate you so so
much
prime doll says david i just got a
warning from nightbot in chat for
sending three clap emojis well i
apologize for that nightbot is very very
overzealous as a moderator
very aggressive extremely so extremely
so
um
i'm told that there is a pro-putin
youtuber
should we look at that let's just check
that out i mean i'm kind of curious
let's see what this is
baklikov live this is a pro putin
youtuber
okay
let's see
um
i don't know let's just let's just look
at a video and see what this is about
[Music]
i have to talk mostly about uh all this
[ __ ] which is happens now
uh between russia and uh ukraine and uh
today there was another
important
event the second
rounds of russian ukrainian talks
well
again uh
not many things happen there
but
it looks like he stands outside for an
hour this is crazy
it seems like they at least started
to find the agreements
and this is something where i'm gonna
talk about today
and uh
also just the latest
news
okay
okay so let's go let's let's walk along
the uh
lego ski prospects
and let's talking
hello janice sir
two sixes cowboy ralph paul
ivan pushkin neil mcdonald's grace this
is weird let's see if there's anything
substantive later on
for the civilians
that
they could evoquate
the sectors where goes the battles
also providing of grocers and uh
providing of the medications to
the zones where it's needed
in the same time yeah guys i don't think
this guy to be totally like just with
total peace and love
i don't know that that guy has the i let
me put a different way
i don't have the russian language skills
to debate him in russian and i don't
know that he necessarily has the english
language skills to really have a debate
in english i'm just not sure so i don't
know if that's a joke that i should
debate that guy or whatever
uh i don't know i don't know but i'm
just
uh
yeah
let's just maybe kind of leave it like
where it is i'm not even sure what to
say hey this is really interesting this
is sort of one of these like hey you
know it would have been useful to know
this before
um william barr now
well just listen to what william barr is
now saying about trump and i told him
that all this stuff was blue
and
about election fraud
and uh
you know i was wrong to be shoveling it
out the way his team was
and he started asking me about different
theories and i had the answers i was
able to tell him this is wrong because
of this you're trying to set him
straight yes and and and you know he
listens now i know many of you are
undoubtedly going to focus on how
william barr sounds terrible and seems
to have a sort of like herpetic cold
sore on his lip
and all these different things don't
focus on that focus on the things that
he's saying
and
he
he was obviously getting very angry
about this i said okay well look i
understand you're upset with me
and i'm perfectly happy to tender my
resignation and then boom he slaps the
desk he slapped the desk and he said
accepted
accept it
and then boom he slapped it again accept
it
go home don't go back to your office go
home
you're done
isn't that the best
now obviously it would have been it
would have been much better to uh you
know
have dealt with this at some point in
the past and be aware of it for sure
uh but i mean it's an interesting
anecdote better better late than never
you know i'm better late than never
um all right people are saying i should
talk to both dylan burns as well as
destiny today i don't know if we can let
me see is are any of them streaming
right
now destiny is
and
dylan burns i don't know if dylan burns
is
um let me see
i don't know exactly
you see if i can raise anybody on
discord just for after this thing
um
let me see here
i know this is last minute i'm live
now have any ability to chat
soonish
okay and then let me check
with destiny
let's see if we can get either of them
on yeah that could be that could be
interesting
that could be interesting okay super
chats you can either listen to only top
10 worst voicemail callers or the
republican state of the union response
for the rest of your life instead of
music what do you choose the the worst
voicemail callers because at least it'll
be new material you know it won't be the
same thing over and over and over again
that's an easy one that was very very
easy
uh oh okay destiny is here let's see
let's check in with destiny just real
quick
um
voice call
let's see
let's see if we can get him stephen
hello hey how are you it's been so long
yeah it has how are you doing buddy
how's uh how's miami treating you
uh great you like it
uh yeah it's pretty cool
do you care where you live it sounds
like you're pretty indifferent
i am but my wife is absolutely not so
she loves it so that makes it pretty
cool oh i didn't know you were married
now
yeah we are oh my god and and uh
well i mean i i
would have sent you don't they say happy
wife happy life right i would have sent
you like a uh you know some kind of pot
or something had i known
what why you drugs that's not okay in
florida
no no no no no no off stream david david
please seriously i don't want to get
banned on twitch
you know those late crusade uh
things i don't know what you get when in
my days we called it um sativa and the
other one so i don't know what any of
that new stuff is no i live in florida
casserole in it or whatever no i think
the uh fbi has like thermal imaging they
can see if you're trying to make it hey
what are you up to these days how's uh
going are you uh are you debating
someone tonight
oh yeah over
ukraine and russia oh is that right is
it what who who are you debating
a couple of tankies one guy is called
infrared and the other guy is called
jackson hinkle wow and they're left
tankies
are they right tankies i don't know i
mean i think at this point everything
exists but
you know what true but um yeah i would
say they're left leaning tankies yeah
okay and are you gonna make the case
that the invasion is bad
bad and completely unjustified yeah of
course yes do you how do you prepare for
such a debate
uh honestly got over the past week i've
been doing a lot of reading history's
not my strong suit so
there's like i'll have to open an
article and i'll have to be like what's
that what's georgia where's that what's
south so said i don't know what any of
these things are so i just have to read
and read and read and read so i'll spend
like a week just
starting on wikipedia then going to
articles and going to interviews and
documentaries and all that [ __ ] and you
do this stuff on your stream or in your
private time
for really big debates i usually do it
privately
because starting
research on a big topic is really hard
because as soon as you start reading
anything everybody's going to be
screaming at you they're like that's a
bad source don't do that don't read the
book so it's better to start on your own
to get like a foundation of knowledge
and then work from there that and and
are you i mean are you reading history
because you plan to make a sort of sort
of his uh historically oriented case for
why what's going on is unjustified
well i think it's kind of important to
understand um history
i hate saying that but it's probably
important to understand the history to
understand the claims being made on both
sides because both sides at least have
the necessary rhetoric or propaganda you
could say to justify what they're saying
but i think historically i think it
becomes more clear who's actually being
truthful and who's not being truthful
that's interesting do you find that this
entire like online debate lord long form
format do you think
does anyone learn from it in a real deep
way do you think
uh i learn a lot when i do research for
my conversations and then typically in
the debate itself that might not be like
a good place for learning because that's
not typically what you're there to do
but the video that gets posted
afterwards people pick up new factoids
that they hear from either side of the
debate and then hopefully there's
ensuing discussions later on about what
was said in the debate and i think
that's where like learning can take
place
do you um
do it like do you do you go in primarily
trying to score rhetorical points
um no absolutely not i used to not care
about the rhetorical or optical points
at all but now i'm a lot more focused on
trying to be a little bit more
rhetorically effective um so i'll try to
like balance both but i mean i'm still
generally just trying to present my side
as truthfully and honestly as possible
interesting
and do you find yourself sometimes in
the middle of these debates going what
the hell am i doing and why did i agree
to this
yeah of course
one time i had a conversation with a guy
over a um it was a huge court case i
don't remember but it ended with a guy
basically asking if i was autistic and i
was like what the [ __ ] what am i even
doing here right now that's crazy i hope
you never spoke to that person again i i
don't even remember who it was for yes i
get weird things all the time but it's
really crazy yeah um hey by the way i'm
gonna be in miami in a couple weeks
maybe we'll like go get hummus or
something
oh i love hummus
yeah
um i'm actually gonna be on the patrick
bet david
show
who's that guy yeah exactly no he has a
he has like a three million subscriber
youtube channel
oh that's a big guy then cool
big time stuff and then do you know
anthony pompliano
i i've heard the name okay
i'm going to be on with him as well and
then i'm going to be at the beach and
then i'm going to be i'm going to be all
over really
awesome yeah
anyway i'll talk to you offline about
that i don't know if you really like do
anything you know so to speak
if that's like friends in the area i'll
go out and hang out yeah for sure maybe
we'll go to brunch again and you can get
pork three ways like last time
it was breakfast of course i'm gonna get
sausage bacon and
yeah i will if you wait if you want to
go to breakfast i'll order seven
different flavors of pork for breakfast
you better [ __ ] believe it yeah like
god damn american i'm even more american
i'm in florida so who do do you feel
this is a serious question i know people
are going to think this is a joke but
it's not
as a cuban american yourself do you feel
like what being now in florida do you
feel kind of like reinvigorated and
reconnected to your cuban roots
um i don't really live in those parts
and i don't really have those friends so
no not at all oh i went to a libertarian
debate conference but i personally just
don't connect like that or at least i
didn't think i connected that but i went
to a weird conference that had like
libertarian debaters there whatever and
there was just a community of cuban
people and those people i actually kind
of thought it was really funny
apparently we have a lot of like shared
experiences growing up a lot of them had
also spent a lot of time in hialeah um
and that was interesting but for the
most part i just don't usually have
cuban friends i don't know
i don't know where they all are do you
feel like you're respected as the top
cuban american streamer on twitch or is
that like recognition i think oh for
sure no i absolutely get that
recognition every time i debate a lefty
streamer they call me gusano so right
it's it's sort of like a backslash it's
a backhanded way of recognizing it i
guess to some degree exactly yeah
hey what did you um
what did you how would you grade the
biden state of the union
um state of the unions are boring i
don't know i don't really care
it's like basically it's like um you
know how like you say whack uh do you
know this on twitch sometimes people say
wacky stuff so they can get clipped and
put on like livestream fails yeah like
views and [ __ ] yeah the state of the
union is like a big like clip
opportunity you're just trying to like
hit every single point so that everybody
has like a different sound bite that
they can play for their shirts but did
you did you watch the entire thing
um yeah we did what what letter grade
would you give it i mean i know you
don't care about it but what would you
give it a grade
[ __ ] dude i don't
i guess like a bee yeah maybe wow that's
exactly i don't think it was that's
exactly what i graded it
okay
it wasn't horrible it wasn't like
amazing but i was like no i thought i
mean i thought it was the right tone on
the ukraine stuff and then in the middle
there was just like a lot of erratic
transitions between vague things
we're going to solve cancer we're going
to fix medication prices we're going to
do minimum wages there's like a ton
immigration reform i was like wow this
is awesome but i mean it's just a state
of the union right yeah hey there is one
bone i do have to pick with you and
actually i have i have to pick this bone
with your wife as well who i did i only
just now learned as your wife
you guys stole obama from me right i
mean can we can we put it out on the
table and just be like you didn't it's
totally fine
i don't even i'm not even sure what
you're talking about wait what did you
say obama obama
obama
i'm just not familiar with domino oh
you're misspeaking
um i'll i'm going to check in with my
community later there are renegade
aspects uh my community is commonly
referred to as the dali ban
but people don't know about the smaller
shootoff uh the al qaeda and sometimes
they run around uh hijacking memes and
stuff so i'll check in uh with some of
my on the ground correspondent to see
what they're up to so yeah i mean it's
just i really am suffering significantly
from from meme jacking there's a guy
named ian vausch who stole enlightened
centrist from me
jesus christ and then you and molina are
taking obama and i'm gonna have very
little allegedly allegedly allegedly
allegedly okay sir
yeah your memes are up in the air right
now so be careful with that one okay
exactly yeah very much so all right and
then otherwise i mean like are you are
you feeling good about where you are in
terms of twitch and the youtube channel
and all these things oh i'm sorry wait a
second no no i think ian vaush stole
gigacringe i don't now i'm unsure
whether he stole enlightened centrist
from me maybe he did i think that's part
of the effort the idea isn't just to
blatantly steal i think the idea is to
steal in such a concealed way and
sometimes to not even steal such that it
creates this culture of confusion where
nobody really knows what's going on
anymore right
it's not like um yeah
yeah
so um
how youtube you're doing okay on youtube
yeah everything's fine i just came out
of a very rough period of my life um
where i went on
a might have been a two-week league
bender i don't know time kind of slips
away from me in that state but um i
survived came out the other side doing
okay and now wait what does that mean
does that mean you abandon everything
other than playing league on stream
and off stream
yeah rough rough period of my life but
we got through it we're all okay and
better off for it so does that cause
tension with molina
um no i told her that like hey we're
married now as part of our marriage you
know we help each other in sickness and
in health and you need to understand
that they're going to be maybe week or
two week long periods where i disappear
into the rift and if you can't accept
that then get the [ __ ] out of my
apartment go back to sweet [ __ ]
basically
man and so did you you're renting right
did you or did you purchase make a real
estate purchase
no we're just running yeah yeah because
you don't know i mean you might settle
there you might not i'm guessing
yeah who knows you know who knows if
it'll be undersea who knows if it'll be
uh succumbing to nuclear fallout you
know the world's pretty unpredictable
right now yeah no that's true renting is
uh more flexible in that sense
yeah for sure do you keep the fact that
you're married kind of on the down low
um
no well okay
[ __ ] why should i no no no i just didn't
know i mean it just it it all came as a
shock to me i have to tell you
oh
okay what why do you why do you say that
well i don't know it just it seemed as
though uh everything was taking kind of
a sort of natural pacing and then before
i turn around and you're married all of
a sudden
well the natural pacing is i can't spend
much time with my wife unless she's a
u.s citizen because she has to go back
to sweden all the time so oh
oh oh oh oh
so there was i mean we don't want to say
anything that would raise
any suspicions about anything but so
there was a wait hold on there are no
suspicions i married her specifically so
that she could be a u.s citizen so we
could live together because we love each
other
it's allowed to do you're allowed to do
that that's why you i mean why you marry
somebody because you want to spend your
life with him you want to know what i
mean is if it's not aren't there
questions as to whether this is really a
bona fide relationship
i mean we've been dating for three years
now we've traveled all over the world
together we know everything about each
other oh are you suggesting it's not a
bona fide relationship no it seemed
almost like you were saying it was of
convenience but i guess it's of
convenience and love
well why do you move in with your do you
live with your wife or girlfriend or
fiance yeah
i live without i
live with probably for both right
convenience and love i would imagine
right you want to be next to them all
the time and you love them right i live
with all three of them
all three of them
okay hmm
interesting yeah
i didn't know you could do that oh [ __ ]
we talked about this actually yeah what
wasn't four and five on the way
yeah right exactly
uh okay well listen i mean you sound
okay you really do you there was a
period there where it was just like you
would become extremely
reactive and like negative oh yeah and
it sounds like you're kind of do you
sound much better maybe it's the way i
don't know we haven't gotten to the uh
um we haven't really brought up any of
those types of topics how do you feel
about ukraine and russia maybe we can
get reactive and negative i'm against
the invasion well that's good i'm glad
to hear it um do you think the do you
think the invasion was the united states
fault no i don't
oh cool all right do you i'm not
no absolutely not okay the thing is i
have a fuse and i've got a cannon and i
want to be shot out of it but it looks
like it's just no reason to light it
right now yeah there's just there's
people who the all they have is a hammer
so then when they look around
everything's a nail and the hammer is
sometimes it's just the us's fault you
know the hammer is that the us is a
horrible dog [ __ ] country and all the
world's problems are because of the
united states essentially yeah and it's
like to some degree
when you are a superpower you're gonna
get involved in a ton of stuff and not
all of it's going to be good but at a
certain point it's like who decided to
invade ukraine it was putin
i don't know it seems so uncontroversial
but hey did you hear rt america's dunzo
um yeah sad i've been on their program a
few times i've been on two but i stopped
going up but you're not really sad are
you
um absolutely not
um i think some of the recent stuff with
what's going with ukraine and watching
other people cover like the artsy stuff
um is a little bit sick to me across
this a little bit of a line i think
whereas kind of before it was like funny
to listen about you know jimmy dore
screaming about how america hates his
citizens because i'm medicare for all or
whatever right but um when it starts to
get into this where you know you've
actually got invasions of countries
going on and then you're seeing like
horrendously one-sided coverage i think
it bothers me a bit more i completely
agree with you and you know there's
people who are saying that it's an act
of censorship but it's like hold on a
second who's censoring i mean cable
cable providers get to decide what
channels they carry no one has a right
to be on a cable network i guess you
could argue that
i mean i don't know could it what's the
strongest argument that could be made
that this is a form of censorship
i i mean it's kind of like a form of
censorship but i don't think that all
censorship is bad right like banning
child pornography as a form of
censorship but is that does that make it
bad would we say well we can't censor
anything you know if you've got like a
foreign state sponsored and
state-directed media agency that's
literally spreading lies and propaganda
you know within your media sphere i
think you have every right as a country
to take steps against that so your view
is it's censorship and it's it's logical
censorship yeah sure i don't think all
censorship is bad i think that's a
really naivety i think we can all agree
that there are some forms of censorship
that are probably okay but you don't see
it as a as an infringement of free
speech but i mean that's just that the
same confused first amendment stuff
people don't get
yeah no i think again i would say that's
like a really naive reading of freedom
of speech that like every every country
around the world has the right to
broadcast whatever they want within our
border i think that's a little crazy
i tend to agree with you i tend to agree
with you
um i'm gonna just one more time are you
ready to cop to stealing obama or are
you still plank gonna play dumb on it
um
i just
um
man i just i really have to i'm gonna
have to think about that one um i just i
can't really comment at the time about
it do you even know what i'm talking
about obama
um i've there are rumors that i've heard
from some people about some meme
thievery going on but i mean these are
you know some of these are state actors
some of these are ngos um i just i don't
know who to trust you know okay
hey one more thing the other day i had a
realization which was if you said to me
or if anybody did
um the next president will be either joe
manchin or mitt romney i'm pretty sure i
would go with romney where do you come
down on that
joe manchester mitt romney i have no
idea
i i don't know right now interesting
interesting
yeah well maybe something for our next
conversation
i love you buddy be careful okay so in
all seriousness should i get in touch
when i'm down in florida or is it sort
of like you're kind of indirectly
telling me not to talk to you
no yeah you can message me we'll hang
out as long as i'm here yeah okay okay
cool and uh we'll see if we'll get
waffles or something
okay cool all right sounds good stephen
kenneth we will talk to you soon
i love you baby careful all right there
he is love you buddy
uh we're gonna be very very careful
there he is folks stephen
kenneth
destiny
bennell
ii
uh good to check in and we're gonna do
the um he's getting away with stealing
obama listen here's the thing
we all know it's sort of like
it's like when police interrogate a
suspect
and you get to a point where the suspect
is still denying it but everybody knows
that they don't really mean the denial
you know
i feel like we did get to that point on
the obama stuff where he's still kind of
denying it but it's very very clear it's
very very clear that it's all for real
um dylan burns we're gonna do something
next week we're gonna do something next
week david love your impression of the
fake laughter check out youtuber baldwin
bankrupt for compelling footage i i
actually i'm a subscriber to bald and
bankrupt's channel i find the guy a
little bit coarse and abrasive to be
perfectly frank but i think that's maybe
what makes the channel a little bit
interesting
um and yes he has a very very
interesting video extraordinarily
interesting video in fact i would say
let me continue thanking people i met i
missed so many thanks to epic hatchet
and um actually
it's just epic hatchet number 28 today
also over on my website thank you to tim
cox
tim is a new member at joinpacman.com
number 29 29 i very very much appreciate
that all right let's do a couple more
voicemails just before we get off of
that
so i went through every zodiac sign
don't care nope i just i don't care
about astrology it is not for me
um oh you guys want to hear something
funny i actually regret this
about
two weeks ago
two weeks ago
i got a um an email from someone saying
they love the show and they would like
to offer me a free tarot card reading
um
and i would like privately and i was
just like i i don't care about that
stuff
um
i yeah i don't believe in it i don't
want it but i'm now realizing like i
should have actually said i will take
the tarot card reading but i want to do
it on the show
that actually would have been
it's a missed opportunity i feel like
i was not considering the content
cade says i'd love to see luke beasley
on the show we're going to hope to do
something with luke again in the future
we need a true deepak steven bennell
crossover possibly a panel or a debate
that's the future we'll look at that
also thanks to rsg2 for the twitch prime
subscription i really really very much
appreciate that okay a couple more
voicemails let's see what we got here
uh david parkman
uh joe biden is making a serious mistake
uh he should not be opening up the
strategic
oil reserves
uh to cover the high cost of
oil yeah troy's the guy you want to go
to for
whether to open up the strategic
petroleum reserve give me a break guys
it's just completely insane all right
let me see if i've got anything else for
you guys
um
let's see here
this guy dave from california leaves
messages all the time but i find them
kind of pedantic so i don't usually play
them but let's try it hey david dave in
california
what putin is doing
to ukraine
i saw
in an old sherlock holmes movie
he's not
killing ukraine all at once
but he's
draining their blood
i don't know about dave in california if
people like him i mean he calls all the
time here's another one
hey david
this is dave in california
i'm getting sick of the coverage
of ukraine
putin
went into somebody's house
and won't leave
and our police force
will not remove them
from that house yeah maybe on 2x speed
that's a possibility
david the um aquarius western sign on
myers-briggs um
got erased
it's um yeah i just don't care about
astrology
i wanted to send a message to europe
but
they no longer have their popular royals
we have them here in the united states
the only reason why anybody praised
the castle in the first place
and crazed europe
was because
of the red hair
and now harry is coming to us
and this [ __ ] no longer matters it's
just some tacky [ __ ]
[ __ ]
uh oh this is richard the third's cousin
whitney really starting to escalate
let's see if i got anything
so what i'm else
out of like the clean energy resources
is that
a lot of people
um
there's a lot of evidence that it's like
still extremely horrible for the
environment
and they're getting away with so much
stuff just because they say it's green i
feel like with whitney i'm always coming
in in the middle of a conversation
hey david uh from alcohol pennsylvania
what really gets me with a lot of the
right wing is they talk about the china
virus
and how we can't let them get away with
it
and yet
we develop a vaccine
to combat the china virus and they still
say
you know what
i'm not gonna take it because that's
gonna kill me too
right it's a tool against the so-called
china virus and they still don't want it
it's it's really crazy
i would love to read tarot cards for you
on the air you can even make fun of me
for it okay
i don't know maybe david can i get a
sound bite of you saying come on guys
when you're annoyed always makes me
laugh i don't have the sound bite
david wanted to tell you your humor is
marvelous compliments compliments the
great show on your the great content on
your show thank you for what you do
thank you geshmake i appreciate that
thank you very very much it's uh
an extraordinary thing to hear from you
all right let's find like one more of
these voicemails and just see
if we can top that last one how about
oh i don't know how about uh
oh here we go here's a good one david
pakman
cnn wannabe propagandist this is joe
from
colorado just wanted to remind you that
your dishonest coverage of covid19
probably a crime against humanity you
failed
now that's actually funny what's funny
is um
yeah okay all right
early treatment
you
encourage the
mrna
treatments
without any
scientific evidence to back it up
false all the
stuff you hear from
cnn
pfizer
what's funny is this guy is like really
upset with my coverage but he's also
like almost no energy like he barely
seems to care enough to complain fake
fake studies
learn do some real research david
instead of just telling what the what
the government wants you to tell
goodbye thank you so much
what a what a resounding
critical voicemail i don't think we will
ever ever survive that
um
i mean how many lies were there in there
the vaccine is not a treatment
and
i mean the research stuff is just like a
waste of time gamer pigeons asked does
whitney realize you've never listened to
more than 10 seconds of any of her
voicemails one time i did one time i did
johnny minogue says whitney's getting so
emotional maybe she just wants to dance
with somebody who loves her that could
be that could be all right guys this
biden thing is late and we really didn't
care about it anyway he's just signing a
bill into law it doesn't have anything
to do with ukraine russia so i'm going
to take the opportunity to get out of
here a little early today uh have one
more show for the week and maybe we'll
stream tomorrow and a bunch of crazy
stuff happening like next week so i
appreciate everybody joining me we've
spoken to stephen kenneth destiny
bonnell ii we've had some laughs we've
cried we've screamed we've done it all
and we'll see everybody back very soon